important that a complaint is made to
the loan provider and ultimately to the
financial homeless Community Services if
that route has been pursued and you're
still and a lot of ladies still needs
some assistance please do contact me I'm
happy to meet her to discuss her father
[Applause]
speaker one of the reasons families in
Scotland are paying some of the highest
electricity bills in Europe is because
of 13 years of failed Tory and SNP
energy policies Scotland is a key
contributor
Inc in delivering a secure affordable
low-carbon Energy System for the whole
of the UK under Labor's proposals we
would lower bills for Scottish
households and be energy independent
with a plan for clean Power by 2020
now the former conservative energy
Minister Claire Perry says labor are
serious about Britain's energy crisis
unlike my former party
the minister agree with his former
colleagues
yeah
[Music]
miss Mr Speaker I do not agree with the
honorable um ladies um analysis this
government remains committed to ensure
the UK has a green securable secured
um energy and Supply which I do agree
with the unrelated assessment of the
snp's and failings and we saw that
yesterday and their approached energy
statements and to the Scottish
Parliament
[Applause]
cheers running
[Music]
Mr Speaker
um I am a trust The Honorable gentleman
recalls that this house overwhelmingly
rejected the motion to which he refers
to because this government is focused on
delivering for the people of Scotland
that means helping tackle on the cost of
living protecting our long-term energy
security and growing our economy
let's go
this place is Secretary of State for
Scotland while explaining the UK
government's lack of appetite for a
referendum in Scotland's place of United
Kingdom repeated many many many times
the route to referendum in 2014 involved
consensus between the governments given
the democracy is fueled by consensus is
a secularism state for Scotland working
towards establishing that consensus as
he content to deny the people of
Scotland their Democratic voice yeah
Mr and speaker the secretary of state
has gold and this government will
continue to work with the Scottish
government to deliver on the priorities
of the people of Scotland that is
dealing with the cost of living that is
dealing with the NHS as it's dealing
with our education system and a long
list of other issues which has got to
give the government are completely
failing to deliver on it is certainly
not another independent referendum
before we come to prime minister's
questions I would like to point out the
British sign language interpretation
proceedings is available to watch our
Parliament live TV we start with
questions of prime minister kelp Smith
question number one Mr Speaker prime
minister
Mr Speaker this morning I had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
in addition to my duties in this house I
shall have further such meetings later
today
there are no NHS dentists taking on
patients in Lancaster and Fleetwood and
for those constituents of mine looking
up to have one they're waiting months
for an appointment so can I ask the
Prime Minister how long he had to wait
for his last NHS dentist appointment
prime minister well miss it
Mr Speaker we as a result of the new
reformed NHS Dentistry contract there
are now more NHS dentists across the UK
with more funding making sure people can
get the treatment they need but Mr
Speaker let me answer the lady directly
I am registered with an NHS GP I have
used independent Healthcare in the past
[Applause]
I have used I have used independent
Healthcare in the past and I'm also
grateful to the far Rich hospital for
the Fantastic care they've given my
family over the years
but the truth is but the truth is Mr
Speaker I'm proud to come from an NHS
family and that's why I'm passionately
committed to protecting it with more
funding more doctors and nurses and a
clear plan to cut the waiting list
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker you are 24 times
more likely to become a doctor if a
parent is a doctor 17 times more likely
to become a lawyer if a parent is a
lawyer and there is a lower proportion
of disadvantaged young people being
admitted to degree level apprenticeships
by employers than two degrees by
universities so I warmly welcome what my
right honorable friends set out last
week about education and family but does
he agree with me we also need our
universities employers and professions
playing their part to improve social
Mobility
okay stop
well Mr Mr Speaker everyone should have
the opportunity to succeed and my
honorable friend is absolutely right
that we all have a part to play that's
why I'm pleased the social Mobility
commission is working to provide new
information to young people about the
opportunities available for them but
also a toolkit for employers that they
can also play their part in improving
social Mobility
thank you Mr Speaker in the 13 years of
the last Labor government there were no
National NHS strikes if the Prime
Minister had negotiated with the nurses
Before Christmas they wouldn't be on
strike
negotiated with the m s workers they
wouldn't be on strike either
why is he choosing to prolong the misery
rather than end these strikes
[Applause]
because we've always been clear that we
want to have constructive dialogue with
the unions that is also that is also why
when it comes to the issue of pay we
have accepted in full the independent
recommendations of the pay-review bodies
then now The Honorable gentleman simply
doesn't have a policy when it comes to
this question if he wants he talks he
talks about wanting to end the stripes
the question for him is simple then why
does he not support our minimum safety
legislation
we all know why we all know why Mr
Speaker it's because he's on the side of
his union pay masters not patients
stop
Mr Speaker when I clap nurses I meant it
is response
his response to the greatest crisis in
the history of the NHS is to threaten to
sack our nurses this transport secretary
says it's not the solution his education
secretary hopes it won't apply in
schools his own assessments say it could
increase the number of strikes the
simple truth is you can't legislate your
way out of 13 years of failure
between 2010 and 2019 before anyone had
heard of covid prime minister the number
of people stuck on the NHS waiting list
double
wider patients always wait longer under
the Tories
this is the new year I want to start off
with the refresh chamber but certainly
not by Interruption prime minister
well Mr Speaker he talks about the
minimum safety legislation let's just
talk about it a little bit further
because this is a simple proposition
that no one no one denies the Union's
freedom to strike but it is also
important to balance that with people's
right to have access to life-saving
health care at the same time Mr Speaker
this this shouldn't be controversial
this shouldn't be controversial the
international labor organization
supports minimum service levels
we we have that they're present in
France in Italy in Spain normally he's
in favor of more European alignment Mr
Speaker why not now
Mr Speaker they've gone from clapping
the nurses to sucking the nurses it's
that simple
and to add insult to injury they're the
cause of the crisis his government
commissioned a report on waiting times
he knows this his own report says this
is not a covert problem it's 10 years of
managed decline as a result 7.2 million
people are now waiting for treatment
he says he wants to be held to account
over that
so let's be very clear is his promise
merely to get those numbers back to
where they were before covid that's 4.6
million or back to where labor had them
in 2010 almost half of that which is it
time is Mr Speaker again let's just
start with the facts The Honorable
gentleman seems to completely ignore the
nor the fact that not just in England
but in Scotland and in Wales and in many
other European countries kovid has had
an extraordinary impact on Health
Services now now we we have a very clear
plan to bring the waiting list down and
it's one that the NHS supports but I
tell you I tell you what the NHS doesn't
need what they don't need is Labor's
eyes idea what we don't need
what they don't need is Labor's only
idea which is for another completely
disruptive top-down unfunded
reorganization buying out every single
GP contract now these aren't my words Mr
Speaker the CEO of the nuffield trust
said it will cost a fortune and it's out
of date just like the labor party
Mr Speaker so he can't tell us how much
he'll reduce waiting list buy or when so
much for accountability that he wants as
ever with this prime minister you
scratch the surface and you find there
is nothing there
last month 1.4 million people waited
more than four weeks for a GP
appointment when labor left government
your guaranteed an appointment in two
days
when does the Prime Minister expect to
get back to that
Mr Speaker when it comes to waiting
lists we've already eliminated two-year
wait list done last year we're on track
we're on track we're on track this
spring to eliminate those waiting 18
months with a clear plan to go further
to eliminate those waiting 52 weeks by
next spring and and we're doing that
with record funding more Community
diagnostic Centers more surgical hubs
and more patient Choice then that's why
Mr Speaker I've made tackling waitlist
one of my five priorities but what what
are his they seem to change every single
week right but first he was against NHS
Outsourcing now he's apparently in favor
of it is inconsistent unprincipled and
in hock to his youth
[Applause]
[Music]
to remind the Prime Minister it's prime
minister's questions the opposition
questions
[Music]
[Applause]
I I had the Prime Minister say s Now
Rich
chess don't
soon enjoy the experience of waiting on
hold every morning at 8am to get a GP
appointment but I can tell him that
those that are waiting now don't want
another round of empty promises or
boasting about what he's done they just
want to know when they'll be able to see
a doctor and this is not just about
routine care
there could be nothing more terrifying
to be told who might have cancer
that's why the last Labor government
brought in a guarantee you'd been seen
by a specialist within two weeks
today 50 000 people are waiting longer
than that 50 000 and everyone in this
house will appreciate the anxiety that
they're feeling so when will cancer
patients once again get the certainty of
Quick Care that they got under labor
[Applause]
Mr Speaker what why why is there a
challenge with cancer times right now I
tell you again again it's just
I just absolutely no understanding of
the situation Mr Speaker what happened
to cancer referrals during covid
they went down by almost two thirds Mr
Speaker that was because of a pandemic
that they went down and by the way if we
had stayed and listened to him we'd
still be in lockdown and there'd be a
bit more waiting left right Mr Speaker
but actually right now there are record
levels of cancer treatment as we catch
up with those missed things but he talks
about what's terrifying Mr Speaker
what's terrifying is right now what's
terrifying is that right now people not
knowing whether when they call 999 they
will get the treatment that they need
now Mr Speaker
not in Australia in Australia and Canada
and the US they banned strikes on Blue
Light Services we're not doing that all
we're saying is that then these
Emergency Services patients should be
able to rely on a basic level of
life-saving care why is he against that
Mr Speaker
there's not a minimum level of service
any day because they've broken the NHS
but he's not promising that people would
get to see a doctorate a few days like
they did under labor he's not promising
that cancer patients would get urgent
treatment as they did under labor he's
not even promising an NHS that puts
Patients First like it did under labor
no he's promising that that one day
although we can't say when the record
high waiting list will stop growing
that's it after 13 years in government
what does it say that the best they can
offer is that at some point they might
stop making things worse
[Applause]
Mr Speaker when it comes to the NHS it's
Crystal Clear the conservatives on the
side of patience labor on the side of
their Union paymasters
speaker I've laid out my priorities for
the country waiting list down inflation
down debt down growth up and the boat
stopped Mr Speaker all he does is flip
from one thing to another and that's the
difference between him and me he's
focused on Petty politics I'm delivering
for Britain
foreign
Falmouth actually I would like to thank
all of the healthcare social care
professions in Cornwall for all of the
hard work they're doing and a
particularly difficult winter in
Cornwall we don't get any respite in the
summer because everybody comes to
Cornwall for their for their holidays
which is brilliant but we so there is no
respite in the summer or the winter for
our Health and Social Care Professionals
and in addition to that Mr Speaker when
we're trying to recruit people into
social care which is a vocation we we uh
there is
they are competing with hospitality and
I would like to ask my right or an old
friend the Prime Minister whether he is
aware of these extra challenges that
police is like Cornwall face in
Recruitment and Retention
well my my honorable friend is
absolutely right to shine a spotlight
and I share with her and be incredibly
proud of all our social care uh workers
for the commitment that they have to
their profession and that's why many of
them will benefit this spring from an
almost 10 increase in the National
living wage putting an extra sixteen
hundred pounds uh in their pacelets but
also we want to make sure that they feel
valued with correct professional
development training and career
progression and the half a billion pound
investment we're putting into the social
care Workforce will do exactly that for
hers and other workers we don't come to
the leader of the SMP Stephen Flynn yeah
Mr Speaker the longest and deepest
recession in the entire G7
exit 13 years of Tory rule the energy
price cases inflation and interest rates
if the people of Scotland Scotland are
to do the math
prime minister
saw him simply doesn't add up
[Applause]
yeah well I'm I'm pleased I'm pleased
The Honorable gentleman brought up
energy and he's right to do that because
energy and when it comes to the economy
is incredibly important to Scotland's
energy and actually Scotland will play a
fantastic part in helping us transition
to Net Zero but what we do now know is
that the Scottish government don't want
to support Scottish energy industry and
the two 200 000 jobs that it produces
I'm Keen to work with a Scottish
government to support the North Sea
because it's something that we're all
very proud of in the United Kingdom
inal Mr Speaker if he wants to talk
about the fact that Scotland is energy
rich but fuel poor on westminster's
watch I am more than happy to do so but
for today let's reflect upon numbers and
in particular those numbers which were
shown a light on by Sam Coates of sky in
particular those in relation to the
prime minister's favorite potential
successor which showed over the course
of four months from four speeches he
raked in in excess of a million pounds
does a prime minister not find it
utterly perverse that senior members of
the conservative party are Feathering
their nest in this way whilst at the
same time seeking to deny working people
the opportunity to strike for fair pay
[Applause]
um well Mr Speaker I did I don't think
we need to talk about our predecessors
but I reckon I remember I remember
[Applause]
I think it was one of his predecessors
that did indeed work for Russia today if
I'm not mistaken but
but I would say is he talks about the
priorities you know yesterday the SM
I'm talking yet more about independence
at a time when we should be talking
about delivering for people across the
United Kingdom focusing on their jobs
improving the NHS across the UK in
Scotland as need as in everywhere else
that's the kind of thing I want to talk
to the Scottish government about and I
hope that he'll work with me to do that
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker
[Music]
[Applause]
of supporting the UK steel industry
[Music]
[Applause]
he will know that steel is a vital
strategic industry it is essential for
everything we do from defense to growth
so can I ask him will he do everything
he can to ensure that we're always able
to make steel in this country does he
agree with me
manifest under a concern
Mr Speaker my honorable friend is a
fantastic Champion for the steel
industry and this government remains
committed to a thriving UK steel
industry that's why our support for
steel includes almost 800 million pounds
in relief or electricity cost and steel
companies are eligible to bid for up to
one and a half billion pounds in capital
grants to speed their transition to net
zero steel
Productions I'm sure the whole house
wish to join me in Wishing all the best
to Gareth Bale the former captain of the
Wales men's soccer team who's been a
national inspiration and took Wales to
the football World Cup this Tory
government attacks dedicated health and
ambulance staff but disruption from
strikes is as nothing nothing compared
with the chronic disruption caused every
day by their 13 years butchering of
Health budgets meanwhile Labor's Health
secretary in Wales follows the Tory
Playbook blaming patients themselves for
the standards of their health but the
reality is this
Health Services in Wales suffer from a
combination of mismanagement by labor
and a Westminster funding system which
perpetuates poverty yeah indeed
[Applause]
out leveling up
Prime militia
[Applause]
you can vote for evidence
well Mr Mr Speaker first of all let me
join with honorable lady as a
Southampton fan Gareth Bale also a hero
of mine as well and I wish him well
um but when it comes to funding Wales
it's as a result of of the funding from
Barnet that the Welsh government
receives around uh significantly more
funding than the NHS in England but also
1.2 billion pounds of extra funding as a
result of the Autumn statement and what
I'd say what I said to the leader of the
opposition this isn't about actually
political Point scoring the NHS is under
pressure in Wales as it is in Scotland
and in England in large part because of
the impact of a global pandemic and she
would do well to recognize that
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker unlike
part is opposite including the Scottish
national party and even the member for
Aberdeen South I know my right honorable
friend supports uh or recognizes the
critical role that oil and gas companies
and their employees critically have not
only providing energy security but also
the liberty of the energy transition to
Net Zero can he therefore confirmed that
this government's or can confirmed this
government's ongoing commitment to
expanding on our country capture our
utilization and storage capacity
including the acorn project in Saint
Vargus and my constituency and can he
provide an update on the track 2
sequencing prime minister
Mr Speaker my honorable friend is a
fantastic champion and campaigner for
this project we will invest up to a
billion pounds to establish carbon
capture and storage in four industrial
clusters by 2030 we very much recognize
the benefits of the Scottish cluster and
the role it could play in
decarbonization and we're progressing
our track through and we'll set out
further details in due course Davis
Jones Mr Speaker the times recently
reported that schools across the UK and
in crisis as the effects of online
influence that Andrew takes a vile
misogyny infiltrates our classrooms and
Society teachers are now having to
develop their own resources to
re-educate boys while being brainwashed
online by his deeply toxic messaging the
Prime Minister has been too slow to
recognize this damages this is causing
what has he done what is government
doing to tackle this misogyny this in
cell culture and the radicalization of
young men in this country and will he
commit to giving teachers the resources
that they need to address this problem
head on
[Applause]
Mr Speaker we've gone to funding we
announced in the Autumn statement two
billion pounds of extra funding for our
scores but I'm also proud that this
government has introduced the world
leading world first Online safety bill
which specifically improves protections
for children and puts very strict
obligations and penalties on Tech
content companies for enforcing them
thank you Mr Speaker the building
the building a brighter future project
Torbay hospital with the biggest single
investment in South Devon's Healthcare
Services since the NHS was founded in
1948. can you assure me the government's
commitment to it remains unchanged
my honorable friend is a fantastic
Champion for his local hospital and his
constituents I'm pleased to say that the
new hospital scheme for Torbay is part
of our plan to deliver dozens more
hospitals by 2030 we will remain
committed to the delivery of that new
hospital and I'm pleased that his his
cross the talking to the new hospital
program team about how to progress those
plans
thank you very much Mr Speaker taxpayers
are set to lose tens of billions of
pounds after the transfer of valuable
public assets to two teaside businessmen
all with those are full and transparent
procurement process and a relative of
one of those people is no benefiting
from millions of pounds worth of scrap
from the same cheese website
prime minister of launch an inquiry into
these truly contracts and whilst he's at
it tell his environment secretary to get
serious about the environmental disaster
of the tea signing course
prime minister oh well Mr Speaker as The
Honorable gentleman will already be
aware uh defra already carried out a
comprehensive evidence-led investigation
considered everything robustly and
concluded that natural causes was most
likely responsible for some of the
things that we saw but we recognize
people want a thorough investigation of
this issue and defra have confirmed that
an independent panel will be set up to
report quickly
thank you Mr Speaker labor control
Bradford Council continually neglect the
needs of Bing Lee and other parts of my
constituency as they pour all of their
money into their inner city heartlands
that therefore my constituents look to
the government in order to put right
their failings that's why the leveling
up fund is so so important so will the
Prime Minister insist that the leveling
up fund for Bingley which has been
submitted which will also unlock many
millions of pounds of private sector
Investments really insists that that bid
is successful when the announcements
made in the news
the labor Council my honorable friend is
a fantastic Champion for his
constituents in Bingley as as as I have
told him previously I can't comment on
individual bids but I wish him every
success and will be following with close
interest how it proceeds
thank you Mr Speaker does the Prime
Minister believe that over 40 000
interactions by either social media
email or letter regarding the poor
customer service and working conditions
at the delivery company every warrants
an investigation by the relevant
government Department his ministers in
Bays think not but I'm sure the Prime
Minister would want the general public
to believe that he at least is
interested enough in this problem to
take action
foreign
Mr Speaker I'm aware that other
government ministers have looked into
this issue and are currently considering
uh the matter at hand and I'd be happy
to write to her when we learn more about
the situation
Mr Speaker does the Prime Minister agree
that the right way to secure the best
future for the British people is to
deliver on the people's priorities and
secure a strong economy yeah and will he
confirm that he will not make any
unfunded spending commitments which
would rack up billions of debt as the
party opposite have done in the last
week
my uh my honorable friend is absolutely
right if we want to safeguard the future
of our public services and make sure
that our young people inherit a strong
economy we must be disciplined on
spending and borrowing she's absolutely
right about no more uh no unfunded
spending commitments unlike it she says
the party opposite at last count 90
billion pounds of unfunded spending
commitments it's the same old label Mr
Speaker they always run out of other
people's money
[Applause]
and this last year my constituent Mr
fakazar a six-year-old daughter has
never seen an NHS dentist she has 10
teeth which are black with Decay and is
often crying with pain
her father feels helpless he's called
every dentist in Wakefield for a place
which hasn't managed to secure one over
25 percent of five year olds in
Wakefield already have visible tooth
decay so when will the Prime Minister
stop dithering and take action to
address our National dental emergency
uh well Mr Speaker I'm very I'm very
sorry to hear about the case raised by
The Honorable gentleman I'm happy to be
happy to look into that specific one
more closely but as I said in answer to
an earlier question we have recently
reformed the NHS Dentistry contract
hundreds of million pounds of more
funding and more dentists which should
make a difference around the country but
I'll write to him on the specific case
[Music]
Street supports and
they scored his jobs but yesterday
Nicholas surgeon's SMP government
published plans calling for as fast as
possible shutdown of the industry and an
end to new Explorations these plans
these ponds are naive unreckless and
were previously previously described by
the SMP leader in this house as crazy so
will the Prime Minister reaffirm his
support for Scotland's oil and gas
workers and the future of our industry
Mr Speaker honorable friend is
absolutely right we know that we will
have to rely on hydrocarbons for decades
to come as we transition to Net Zero and
consuming oil and gas from the North Sea
means less than half the carbon
footprint of importing that same oil and
gas which is obviously makes sense to do
it here and in the process support tens
of thousands of jobs in Scotland so I
can reassure him that the Scottish oil
and gas industry has this government's
wholehearted support Cordova
thank you Mr Speaker the Tory crisis in
the NHS includes Ophthalmology the
largest and busiest outpatient service
there are more than 650 000 people
waiting to see AI care specialist
will the Prime Minister back my bill
calling for a national Eye Health
strategy that would ensure that nobody
waiting for two CA specialist will go
about and potentially lead to a complete
loss of sight
and I I Thank The Honorable lady for her
campaigning in this area and we are
taking action to improve things over the
past five years the National Institute
for Health and Care research has
invested more than 100 million pounds to
support Research into eye conditions but
I know that there's more can do and we
can do in my honorable friend the
minister I believe is sitting down to
talk to The Honorable lady in due course
and I look forward to hearing about
those comments in Duncan Smith
speaker today I and others met with
Sebastian Lai the son of Jimmy Lai who
languages in prison the ex-owner of
Apple Daily I remind my right normal
friend that he is a British Citizen and
a British passport holder and he now
faces a trial at the end of the year in
which he can be incarcerated under the
new National Security laws for life
for what for publishing truth to power
will my right honorable friend please
now direct the rest of his government
particularly the foreign office now to
warn the Chinese government if they
persist with this he and alongside the
Americans have already done this will
threaten that the use of common law in
Hong Kong will be taken away
[Applause]
but Mr Mr Speaker my ronaldomore Fran
speaks with authority on these issues
and I thank him for his continued
engagement on this critical issue I he
knows the actions we have already taken
with regard to Hong Kong not least
providing Refuge uh for hundreds of
thousands of people here and being
robust in standing up to what we believe
to be Chinese aggression and indeed an
undermining of the settlement that we
fought so hard to achieve uh he has my
absolute Assurance I will continue to
remain engaged and robust on this and I
look forward to sitting down with him to
discuss this particular issue in more
detail as soon as possible
thank you Mr Speaker half of British
women and a fifth of men have been
sexually harassed at work or a place of
study the government's own figures show
that 41 of those said their perpetrators
face no consequences thanks to
cross-party and government support my
private members bill which has now
passed committee stage will bring about
a culture change to protect workers from
harassment and sexual harassment both
from fellow employees and third-party
individuals will the prime minister
joined me in celebrating the cross party
work on this important change in the law
and by personally supporting its aims
and objectives and ensuring its safe
continued Passage through this
Parliament here prime minister can I
Thank The Honorable lady for her
important work on this issue and sexual
harassment has absolutely no place in
the workplace and everyone should be
able to feel safe at work now of course
we need to make sure that legislation
doesn't have unintended consequences but
I know she is meeting with my right
honorable friend the minister for women
inequalities to discuss her bill further
and I look forward to hearing her
progress on that meeting thank very much
Mr Speaker does the Prime Minister agree
with me that the disgusting anti-semitic
anti-vaxx conspiracy theories that have
been promulgated online this morning are
not only deeply offensive but
anti-scientific and have no place in
this house or in our wider Society
[Applause]
well can I join with my writable friend
in completely condemning those types of
comments that we saw this morning and
the strong or strongest possible terms
obviously it is utterly unacceptable to
make linkages and use language like that
and I'm determined that the scourge of
anti-Semitism is eradicated it has
absolutely no place in our society and I
know that the previous few years have
been challenging for the Jewish
community and I never want them to
experience anything like that ever again
final question now here with
thank you Mr Speaker
a 95 year old constituent of mine spent
41 hours in a e
when will the Prime Minister admit that
the NHS is collapsing because of 13
years of underfunding and do something
about it instead of blaming the nurses
striking to save it
prime minister
Mr Speaker first of all I'm very sorry
to hear about the experience of the
elderly constituent that The Honorable
lady raised and my sympathies go out to
her but this is not about blaming
anybody this is about recognizing that
the NHS weather in Scotland whether in
Wales where it is run by the labor party
whether here in England is facing
pressure as we recover from a pandemic
the right thing to do is to have a clear
plan in place to work with doctors and
nurses to ease that pressure that's what
we're focused on doing and that's what
our plans will deliver
right that completes prime minister's
questions we'll just let the German
clear